welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this the White House is scrambling
to contain the growing crisis in Syria
after President Trump's decision to
withdraw most US troops from the country
Turkey's invasion of northern Syria
targeting us back Kurdish fighters and
civilians has now entered its seventh
day Syrian government forces backed by
Russia are now taking control of key
cities in that area
president Trump called on Turkey to end
the invasion yesterday the White House
announced sanctions to punish turkey and
mr. Trump said he was halting
negotiations on a trade deal Ben Tracy
is at the White House Ben what else is
the president doing well good morning so
the president is also sending a senior
delegation to Turkey including vice
president Mike Pence to try to broker
some sort of peace now as for the
sanctions that the u.s. is hitting
turkey with a source tells CBS News that
even here at the White House there are
some who don't think these sanctions
will change turkeys mind the president
of the United States called on the
president turkey to stop the invasion
vice president Mike Pence attempted
damage control as criticism ounce of
president Trump's abrupt decision to
withdraw troops from Syria allowing for
turkeys invasion we want an immediate
ceasefire and we want to begin
negotiations between Turkey and Syrian
defense forces the administration's
initial statement announcing the
withdrawal of troops set no boundaries
for turkeys military operation
but after bipartisan backlash president
Trump vowed to destroy turkeys economy
if it went through with this kind of
invasion if there wasn't there should
have been a very clear sanctions threat
provided during that conversation to
prevent exactly what erawan ended up
doing now the White House is hitting
turkeys top government officials and
ministries with sanctions doubling steel
tariffs to 50% and cancelling
negotiations over a 100 billion dollar
trade deal these sanctions are very very
strong well the US will keep some troops
in the region to prevent an Isis
resurgence the president is broadly
sticking by his initial decision to pull
out and boasting of defeating 100
percent of the Isis Caliphate as for the
Kurdish fighters who were crucial in a
Publishing that mr. Trump also said let
Syria and Assad protect the Kurds Bashar
al Assad Syrian government a bitter
enemy of the United States he is backed
by Russia this alliance between the
Kurds and Assad is not good for us
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell issued a strongly worded
statement Monday saying he was gravely
concerned by our nation's apparent
response thus far and that withdrawal
would create a broader power vacuum in
Syria that will be exploited by Iran in
Russia now a source tells CBS News that
there are some officials in the
administration who recognize that this
is devastating for US influence in the
region but this source also says there
is no one left in this administration
that could act as a counterweight to
President Trump
Anthony Ben thank you